[Music]
as every branch of the military is
reportedly in a recruiting crisis its
top brass is still doing everything it
can to deter people from wanting to join
case in point back in november defense
secretary lloyd austin made it mandatory
for service members to get the covet
vaccine many have been fighting it and
today we learned that roughly forty
thousand national guardsmen and twenty
two 000 reservists who have refused to
the vaccine will be barred from their
duties effectively cutting their pay and
benefits joining me now former secretary
of state mike pompeo he's also a fox
news contributor mr secretary what will
getting rid of more than 60 000 service
members do to our military readiness
raymond thanks for having me on tonight
you mentioned the recruiting problems
we're already facing
when you make a military welcome when
you don't do the right things by
focusing on its wartime mission and then
you add to that cutting will amount to
between 10 and 15
of all national guardsmen this is really
dangerous i i assure you that xi jinping
and vladimir putin are not worried about
the vaccines they're worried about
making their militaries more capable we
should be focused on the same thing
there's a real risk to readiness a real
risk to making sure that we have units
that are capable of deploying should
something be required of them this is
this is silly it's not based on science
it makes no sense and i hope this
president will change his ways and i if
there's a a president after him he
should reinstate every one of these
folks that they deny the capacity to go
do what they're trying to do to serve
voluntarily on behalf of the united
states of america particularly what
we're learning now about herd immunity
and that so many people are already
having who haven't been vaccinated have
gotten coveted and therefore they are
immune at this point i want to turn to
the assassination of former japanese
prime minister shinzo abe
the media reaction was frankly
disgusting mr secretary npr tweeted then
deleted that abe was a divisive arch
conservative and cbs this morning
remembered him this way
a polarizing figure he was a right-wing
nationalist and conservative and a
fierce supporter of japan's military mr
secretary who exactly was he polarizing
too he was the country's longest-serving
prime minister who won by huge margins
raymond this is sick it's sick to see
these left-wing media folks go after a
man who was just assassinated he was
assassinated by the way while he was
campaigning
for his party for his ideas for the
things that actually have benefited the
japanese people for an awfully long time
there is a reason he was the longest
serving prime minister the people of
japan loved him and revered him he'd
become a friend of mine too he was a
great partner for the united states of
america and so to hear npr and cbs come
after him for being some right-wing
crazy well he delivered really good
outcomes for the japanese people and he
was a great partner to the united states
that doesn't surprise me that someone
who did that who worked alongside us in
the trump administration uh being
attacked by the leftists is the same old
tired story
i regret that they would do that at the
time where this man was assassinated in
his own country terrible fbi director
christopher wray yesterday talked about
one of the greatest threats facing our
country mr secretary watch
we consistently see that it's the
chinese government that poses the
biggest
long-term threat to our economic and
national security and by our i mean both
of our nations along with our allies in
europe
and elsewhere now i seem to remember
president biden highlighting far greater
threats
you know what the joint chiefs told us
the greatest threat facing america was
global warming according to the
intelligence community
terrorism from white supremacy is the
most lethal threat to the homeland today
not isis not al qaeda
white supremacists
mr secretary who's right ray or biden
i'm with the ray ray nailed it ray's got
it exactly right the chinese communist
party has been abusing the american
people they've stolen millions of our
jobs uh they've taken away intellectual
property they've stolen our secrets in
our universities director ray has this
right the chinese communist party not
not climate change not white supremacism
actually present real risk to every
american all across this country
and they're probably uh
incensed uh the media as well as parts
of the biden administration about the
abe um
you know with abe missing there is a
regional
balance here that we are losing talk to
us about what that means and and what we
may have lost in abe being assassinated
here
prime minister abe was really the first
and most significant asian leader to
confront the chinese communist party
it's hard when you're in
their neck of the woods there in the
pacific but he was serious about it he
partnered with australia with the south
koreans uh with our other allies in the
region and of course with us to deliver
a central understanding about the
chinese communist party the very one
that director ray spoke of there he was
fearless in supporting that and we've
lost a great leader who was willing to
really change the trajectory of japan's
willingness to defend itself in the
countries in the region
there's a real risk today whether that's
taiwan or japan itself or the south the
south central parts of the pacific
was a fierce defender he's no longer
there and this presents increased risk
not only to them but to the united
states of america as well mr secretary
thank you for your insight tonight hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else